c'est vrai la malaisie c'est que
l'émission ce 15 décembre dernier vous
le savez on avait surtout parlé de cette
cérémonie pour une raison la polémique
autour des images de miss de la miss qui
était ce un nu diffusé en irak et
maintenant presque dix mois après les
faits manon jean mistral confirme à
corse matin qu'elle n'a pas renoncé à sa
plainte contre la boîte de production
je vous le dis donc pendant la soirée
les caméras de tf1 s'était introduite
dans les loges dévoilons des millions et
des millions de téléspectateurs
démission petites tenues dont deux
d'entre elles seins nus voilà on les a
réussis et donc est là elle décide de
porter plainte ce qui me poursuit le
plus c'est l'incident le soir de miss
france on attend des nouvelles je ne
compte pas m'arrêter
même si on devait me destituer si je me
défends c'est ma personne qui ait touché
pas l'ami c'est pour ça que le comité
miss france me soutient de c'était manon
jean mr alkaly disent ah voilà oui mais
moi ce que je comprends pas c'est qu'en
fait on avait totalement oublié
ben oui elle en reparlant de salle elle
n'a pas oublié mais qu'elle le garde
pour elle et qu'elle maîtrise à son
avocat mais pourquoi le dire
publiquement tous qu'on est recherché
ces photos alors koné revoir soir etc
sur et réseaux sociaux elle sans
principe l'intérêt d'avoir à chaque fois
on lui reparle de sado qu'elle en a l on
a sacré faut bien qu'à un moment donné
on arrête d'en parler pour que ça
s'apaise il y aura deux victimes plus
tard mais le scénar par les annonces
j'ai peur que ça lui reviennent dans la
tronche en soit les yeux c'est par
internet n'oublie pas tu tapes scandale
mi-séance et tu tombes sur sur man on
man les tétons à l'air alors que c'est
tout à fait j'ai qu'on tape son nom
tombe direct demandeur sur des choses
c'est pas des bonnes alors nous loue ce
qui se passe et l'américanisation c'est
que tout se règle à part les avocats ne
sont pas des bonnes conditions
tout se règle voilà par des plaintes et
est faux c'est l'américanisation de la
société quoi on ne regarde quoi
passionner
oui maintenant la nourriture et la
manière de traiter les problèmes
[Musique]
l'américaine à l'américaine semble mais
ce qui est étonnant c'est qu'il n'ait
pas réussi à trouver un terrain
d'entente et peut-être des choses à
l'amiable entre angel et d'argent ou de
la préfecture ans ils se sont excusés
elle dit que c'est lui qui viennent il a
présenté ses plus plates excuses elle
dit que la société endemol lui ai envoyé
des fleurs etc
donc ils ont essayé de trouver quelque
chose est ce qui est étonnant c'est que
ça continue et que quand on est très bon
mais quasiment un an presque un an après
on en ressort est encore cette affaire
là donc se comprend qu'elle soit
absolument blessés c'est le serpent
casse mais en revanche sa sincère en
tout cas pour nos jeunes amis qui nous
regardent ce jeune danny care fait qu'
il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de bulle
bly numérique et que donc on craint que
l'on se prenne en photo que ce soit au
bout du rouleau bruiteur etc je suis
donc s'éclater chouchou 5e chroniqueurs